a number of Republicans in Congress had
been deeply skeptical of the way the FBI
is handling the Russia investigation and
other cases now one congressional
Republican thinks he may be facing
retaliation for not properly kowtow to
the deep state congressman Louie Gohmert
of Texas says that friends the
intelligence world have warned him he is
being watched by the US government he
didn't take it seriously he says now he
is reconsidering that congressman
Gohmert joins us tonight congressman
thank you for coming on great to be with
you tug or any time so look I last year
and a half has taught us that nothing is
impossible and so I'm open-minded about
everything but it's a it's a pretty
heavy charge why do you think it is true
well actually I've been told by a number
of different people in position to know
that you know you're being watched -
you're being listened to and you know
you just brush it off you can't let
those kind of things control your life
and then I did a 48-page expose on
Muller and it really came home as how
prepared that my gosh this is this is
this their mode of operation this is
what they do
and then when you see they've destroyed
Kurt Wheldon's political career two
weeks before his election rating in
office and and doing nothing with it but
now they're bringing his name back up
years and years later because I
understand he's about to come out with a
book to disclose what all the
manipulations that were look at Ted
Stevens I mean as Steve Hatfill I mean
they know how to ruin people's lives and
you I've not mentioned this before but
we had a private conversation with some
of the people in our intelligence after
we found out about our amassing what
right now what does it mean though this
but by spying would that be monitoring
your email phone calls bugging your
office and what is love and I'm told by
one of our folks that they know
everybody that walks through your office
door before they get to the door so you
know they they being whom that would be
the u.s.
well FBI intelligence and didn't
for a day but I've had people in those
departments tell me you know they're
they're watching they're listening for
whatever you may take wouldn't that be
I'd look again I'm totally open mind
doesn't want to believe it cuz it seems
like that right like a constitutional
crisis they're not you're a member of
Congress elected these are bureaucrats
unelected you serve in an oversight role
over them if they're spying on you then
I mean the whole system falls apart or
he's following about if there's a lying
on a presidential candidate or a
president after he's been elected those
kind of things it turns out we're going
on and but I started mentioned I think
I've told a private group of our
intelligence folks either you give us
the names of those people who unmasked
all of those people that should never
been unmasked our work I'm gonna make it
my life's work to get rid of this
program that allows you to do it and I'm
not saying this is why but very quickly
they did come out with the names we knew
you know Susan Rice allegations folks
like that right and and I think we're
better for knowing those names Congress
under thank you and I hope that if you
find I can't live in deserts and they're
not gonna back hear me Amen thank you
we'll keep moving on congressman
government